There's not one connection between
mathematics and music there are many.
It's got so much mathematics in the rhythms
the patterns, even the counting.
The way that frequencies match up
to produce sounds that we
find pleasing together.
The mathematician Leibniz said that music
is what happens when we do mathematicsunconsciously.
You can't listen to a piece of Bach without knowing
that it's mathematical.
Thebeautiful patterns and symmetries in that music
if you're listening to a fugue or playing a fugue onthe piano
you'll get a theme that comes in
and then it comes back but it's upside down, inverted.
Or it might be retrograde, backwards.
People somehow they get put off the idea of mathematics.
Theythink mathematics is about numbers and numbers are not creative, they're rigid.
Whereas artis more free and creative.
The most creative subject for me is mathematic,
it's just thatwe're creating with with ideas, with patterns.